[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 2 juin voici les
titres
retour sur les assises du numérique la
deuxième édition se tenait ce mercredi
aux pyramides du port marly des tables
rondes et ateliers autour du numérique
pour l'éducation les territoires et
bâtiments connectés la e-santé la cyber
sécurité dans les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine des
consultations juridiques gratuites elles
sont possibles dans les points justice
du territoire un professionnel du droit
vous apporte son aide sur des questions
spécifiques comment y avoir accès et
pour quoi faire on fait le point dans
cette édition
et puis découverte d'un lieu
emblématique des yvelines souvent
méconnus par rapport au château de
versailles le domaine de marly le roi a
été distingué par le ministère de la
culture le site de 4 dans ha vient
d'être labellisé jardin remarquable
une véritable reconnaissance pour les
équipes sur place
présentation aussi dans cette édition du
à 14e salon lisez local des auteurs du
territoire conviés par la librairie du
pavé du canal à montigny le bretonneux
c'est ce samedi on en parle tout à
l'heure avec notre invité laurent gara
[Musique]
avant de développer ses titres fin du
suspense pour quelques neuf cent trente
six mille jeunes ce jeudi soir à partir
de 19 heures les lycéens pourront
consulter les réponses à leurs voeux
d'orientation formulées sur la
plateforme parcours sup s'ouvre
désormais la phase d'admission jusqu'au
14 juillet des propositions sont envoyés
aux candidats qui ont un délai de
quelques jours seulement pour donner
leur réponse la date limite est indiquée
à chaque fois pour vous aider des
conseillers parcours sub sont joignables
tout au long de cette phase d'admission
via la messagerie contacts directement
depuis votre dossier ou par téléphone au
numéro vert qui s'affiche le 0 800 400
0,70 et des sessions de chat on là ils
vont être également proposée par park ou
cieux parcours sup cette semaine avait
donc lieu la seconde édition des assises
du numérique de port marly au port-marly
c'est un événement organisé par sn et
yvelines numériques en partenariat avec
le département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine cette journée était
rythmée par des ateliers des tables
rondes autour de différents enjeux du
numérique et notamment celui de la
cybersécurité mathilde franco était sur
place
aujourd'hui je me trouve aux assises du
numérique à port-marly c'est la seconde
édition tout au long de la journée se
dérouleront des ateliers des tables
rondes sur différents thèmes comme la
santé l'éducation ou encore la cyber
sécurité mais tout d'abord pour
présenter l'événement on va aller à la
rencontre du président de seine et
yvelines numériques bertrand coquard
fait partie
[Musique]
seconde édition des assises du numérique
c'est important c'est un moment
important pour les villes les élus est
également nos partenaires de pouvoir se
rencontrer et présenter les différentes
options que propose sony numérique assez
à ses usagers adhérents donc on est sur
la cybersécurité on est sur la santé
bref on est sur le numérique au sein des
collectivités plusieurs communes des
yvelines en ont été victimes ces
derniers jours aujourd'hui la
cybersécurité devient un enjeu
primordial
alors comment se prémunir d'une
cyberattaque l'adjudant chef de la
gendarmerie des yvelines nous aide à y
voir plus clair alors c'est un peu dur
parce qu on a différents types de
cyberattaques donc le problème il est là
c'est que de manière générale de manière
générale en fait il ya toujours des
solutions qui sont à peu près on va dire
qu'ils peuvent être d'attaqué à tous va
déjà avoir une gestion des mots de passe
avoir effectivement des postes qui voir
des identifiants et mots de passe par
personne à voir aussi bas des mises à
jour des logiciels des mises à jour de
leur antivirus éviter de brancher
n'importe quoi sur son ordinateur donc
voilà est aussi avoir une politique de
communication et d'informer surtout
quand j'étais tout à l'heure de
formation de ses personnels parce que si
le personnel qui utilisent le réseau
informatique de collectivité n'est pas
formé bas donc il ne sait pas quoi faire
pour éviter son attaque et surtout il ne
connaît pas la réaction qui doit avoir
pour peut-être éviter de propager cette
attaque tout simplement le secrétaire de
mairie un jour a essayé de se connecter
pour faire une action sur le pc de la
commune et s'est aperçu que toutes les
données étaient cryptées donc il m'a
appelé en catastrophe ont pour me dire
allez vite à la mairie ce passe quelque
chose et c'est parce que lui à distance
puisqu'il est à 10 km ne pouvais pas
arrêté le système je suis là pour
témoigner justement de ce qui nous est
arrivé de ce qu'on a mis en place et
puis surtout alerter les gens que il est
tout le monde est concerné et quoi c'est
surtout ça papa comme moi penser que
naïvement santo arrivé qu'à des grosses
entreprises ou des grosses
administration voilà clap de fin pour
cette seconde édition des assises du
numérique beaucoup d'autres sujets ont
été évoqués tout au long de la journée
comme la vidéo verbalisation les outils
connectés ou encore la lutte contre les
dépôts sauvages grâce au numérique au
total quatre tables rondes 19 ateliers
pour éduquer et sensibiliser au
numérique nous reviendrons sur les
différents thèmes abordés au cours d'une
émission spéciale 7,8 dossier qui sera
consacrée justement à ces assises du
numérique le 24 mai dernier se tenait la
journée nationale de l'accès au droit
dans ce cadre le tribunal judiciaire de
versailles a accueilli des consultations
gratuites de professionnels de droit
destination du grand public l'occasion
d'évoquer cette question de l'accès au
droit dans les yvelines avec vous
nicolas landry bonsoir bonsoir et la
rédaction de tv 78 vous étiez présent au
tribunal judiciaire pour cette journée
comment s'est-elle déroulée et bien
grégory il y avait trois professions qui
ont participé à ces consultations il y
avait onze avocats 4 notaire et deux
huissiers des consultations gratuites
sur rendez vous dans trois box du
tribunal judiciaire de versailles au
total 45 personnes 45 personnes ont été
reçues durant cette journée l'objectif
donner des informations générales sur
différentes questions juridiques et les
rendez-vous ont été concluants écoutez
c'est une bonne idée d'organiser ces
journées surtout quand on ne sait pas
trop vers qui se
ce retourné j'ai fait des recherches sur
internet et qu'on sait pas trop si on
tombe sur les bons sur les bons
formulaire sur les bons principes
d'envoi ou de transmission ne serait ce
qu'au juge des tutelles elle m'a donné
toutes les réponses et pour me conforter
dans l'idée que ce que j'ai trouvé sur
internet ça correspondait à ce qu'on
cherche vraiment au niveau des dossiers
envoyés la consultation gratuite et très
très efficace j'ai posé un certain
nombre de questions et de courants avoir
des conseils donc aux notaires et qui
m'a qui m'a aidé en comprenant bien mais
quelles sont les questions posées par
ces personnes en consultation ce jour là
il y avait plusieurs questions surtout
du droit civil des sujets de différentes
différents en fonction des
professionnels par exemple les huissiers
ont été consultés sur des affaires de
logements insalubres ou d'exécution de
décision les notaires ont orienté les
personnes reçues notamment sur les
questions de patrimoine ou de succession
et enfin les avocats bce qui ont le plus
de sujets à traiter puisque c'est
beaucoup plus large c'est du droit de la
famille des droits des étrangers ou
encore du droit du travail est sur place
j'ai rencontré un notaire une notaire
est une avocate écoutez sûrement à des
étrangers c'est souvent la
régularisation de séjour la
naturalisation l'a visiblement gêné
progrès tic des îles en aussi donc voilà
c'est ça beaucoup d'accès d'accès au
territoire et surtout accès à la
régularisation est un titre de séjour ce
sont souvent des questions liées à l'or
un contentieux donc effectivement là il
faut prendre le temps d'étudier le cas
pour pouvoir apporter une réponse la
plus précise possible
ou des questions parfois tout simple qui
n'ont pas été posées un professionnel en
amont ce qui est pareil plus surprenant
mais voilà c'est la réalité souvent des
questions liées au droit de la famille
dont contentieux en droit de la famille
liée à une situation de successions
compliquées de séparation compliqué
voilà donc souvent du contentieux mais
je vous dis ça peut être des questions
également plus simple qui paraissent
anodines et voilà qu'ils qui apporte
auquel on apporte une réponse
pragmatique or le 24 mai c'était la
journée nationale de l'accès au droit
c'est consultation était organisée au
tribunal judiciaire de versailles mais
en fait il n'y a rien d'exceptionnel à
ces consultations gratuites vous pouvez
très bien vous rendre chez votre notaire
ou chez votre avocat pour avoir pour les
consulter sur des informations gratuites
mais c'est aussi la mission du conseil
départemental d'accès au droit
l'organisateur de cette journée au
tribunal mais sa mission en fait au
quotidien c'est d'informer le grand
public sur des questions juridiques avec
des professionnels du droit à une
vingtaine d'associations pour cela vous
avez 17 points de justice dans le
département des yvelines trois maisons
de justice et du droit répartis sur
l'ensemble du territoire et à la tête du
conseil départemental d'accès au droit
bc bertrand mener le président du
tribunal judiciaire de versailles que
j'ai rencontré aussi c'est une façon de
montrer aux personnes qui ont un besoin
et qu'ils veulent voir un professionnel
du droit qu il y a aussi des actions que
tout certes y ait des actions payant
mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'actions
gratuites et que on peut au moins dans
un premier moment de renseignement
obtenir assez facilement et partout sur
le département des yvelines
une information si on a besoin
d'approfondir ici on a besoin de faire
appel aux professionnels pour mener une
action soit on a des revenus
insuffisants et on bénéficie d'une aide
d'état qu'on appelle l'aide
juridictionnelle soit en a les moyens de
payer son avocat son huissier ou sans
notaire et on le rémunère dans un cadre
plus approfondie or j'insiste là dessus
c'est vraiment des informations
juridiques on peut pas lancer de
procédure gratuitement et donc les
demandes sont en hausse et auprès des
maisons de justice et du droit et des
points de justice des yvelines quarante
mille personnes ont fait des demandes en
2021 et si vous avez une question à
résoudre si vous avez justement une
information juridique a demandé vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran c'est le
site du conseil départemental d'accès au
droit merci nicolas pour ce point
d'information à propos de ce sujet très
important à ce oui de l'accès au droit
le ch'ti tube recherche ces nouvelles
entreprises l'incubateur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance un
nouvel appel à candidatures les porteurs
de projets ou de services d'innovation
technologique et les dirigeants de start
up peuvent candidater jusqu'au 24 juin
les lauréats pourront bénéficier d'un
programme d'incubation de 6 à 24 mois
d'un accompagnement personnalisé et
avoir le soutien d'experts est
thématique une réunion d'information se
déroulera le jeudi 9 juin à 14 heures
c'est au ski cuba était situé à
guyancourt depuis son ouverture il ya
cinq ans l'incubateur est épaulé une
soixantaine d'entreprises
[Musique]
régiment 10 avant le premier tour des
élections législatives rendez vous aux
urnes le 12 juin pour élire vos députés
tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir plus clair
dans ce scrutin avec elle les enjeux
dans chacune des 12 circonscription des
yvelines avec moi ce soir aussi bixente
manière senti stevan de la rédaction tv
78 bonsoir bixente et avec vous on va
parler précisément d'une circonscription
et pas des moindres elle regroupe
cinquante et une commune presque un
tiers du département c'est la 10e
circonscription en effet vous avez te
dit gregory en fait quand on prend la
carte des yvelines il ya deux
circonscriptions facilement
identifiables par leur vente superficie
la 9ème à l'ouest et surtout le sud du
département donc la 10e elle débute de
maurepas et montfort l'amaury au nord et
décent jusqu'en bas de la carte
comprenant rambouillet
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines l'histoire
politique de cette circonscription est
très ancrée à droite avec quelques
exceptions surtout depuis les dernières
années de 1993 à 2007 c'est christine
boutin qui occupe le poste de député sur
la circonscription en tant que
représentante de l'udf puis de l'ump
réélu en 2007 mais choisi comme ministre
du logement et de la ville elle laisse
son siège à son suppléant jean frédéric
poisson et c'est là que ça se complique
après le remaniement ministériel de 2009
elle cède sa place de député ce qui
entraîne une élection législative
partielle remportée donc par
jean-frédéric poisson mais invalidée par
le conseil constitutionnel
une nouvelle des élections et donc
organiser des suites de celle là en
juillet 2010 et c'est une surprise le
parti europe ecologie les verts brigue
la mandature avec avec anny poursinoff 1
reste deux ans et en 2012 le retour de
la droite à la tête de cette 10e
circonscription avec jean frédéric
poisson encore désormais sous le parti
chrétien démocrate
partie justement fondée par christine
boutin et enfin lors des dernières
élections la vague lrm aura eu raison de
ce territoire historiquement à droite
aura berger est élu au deuxième tour
avec 64 % de suffrages exprimés et
hazard des chiffres pour cette nouvelle
campagne des élections législatives dans
cette 10e circonscription où une dizaine
circonscription avec dix candidats
officiellement inscrits en vue des 12 et
19 juin prochains on est sur une zone
convoitée par donc le parti de la
majorité présidentielle avec l'actuel
député rohr berger qui se représentent
mais le territoire est également briguée
par d'autres partis les républicains
tout d'abord ancrés localement est
représentée par anne k brimer redore son
ville et directrice du parc naturel
régional de la vallée de chevreuse
autres forces en présence nuxe l'union
de la gauche avec cédric bo l'est de la
france en soumises habituellement dans
les hauts-de-seine qui a déjà été
candidat au départemental à nanterre et
à la région ile de france et thomas du
chalard un temps directeur de la
communication de la mairie est reine de
mantes la ville pour le rassemblement
national pour rappel au premier tour des
présidentielles sur ce territoire jean
luc mélenchon avait récolté 19 % des
voix marine le pen 16% bien en dessous
des manuels macro à 32% plus violents
sur lire dans le détail parmi les
candidats alignés en 2017 peut se
représenter en 2022 trois seulement sur
les quinze inscrits il ya cinq ans en
plus d'horreurs berger donc deux sont à
nouveau là en 2022 philippe chevrier
anciens rn désormais sous l'étiquette du
parti d'eric zemmour reconquête et
marielle saunier pour le parti de la
lutte ouvrière tous deux avaient récolté
moins de 1% des suffrages en 2017 enfin
pour terminer ce tour d'horizon quatre
autres candidats civils beau gars pour
le parti animalistes claire couégnas de
debout la france michel bizien du parti
ouvrier indépendant et patrice jacono
sans étiquette merci bixente on rappelle
les dates de ce scrutin des élections
législatives premier tour le 12 juin et
2e tour le 19 juin prochain
[Musique]
située à quelques kilomètres du château
de versailles il est souvent méconnu le
domaine de marly le roi vient d'être
labellisé jardin remarquable par le
ministère de la culture à un véritable
une véritable même reconnaissance par
les employés de cet écrin de verdure de
97 hectares le reportage de mathilde
franco
apaisant relaxant le domaine de marly le
roi fait penser à un petit versailles
avec son canal ses statuts et ses
grandes allées main beaucoup plus calme
[Musique]
méconnu du grand public ce dernier reste
souvent dans l'ombre de son voisin le
célèbre château de versailles pourtant
et vient d'être labellisé jardin
remarquable par le ministère de la
culture une reconnaissance qui a demandé
au personnel en charge du dossier
beaucoup de travail pour remplir les
critères demandés à la manière de
présenter le site le jardin également
sur le patrimoine architectural s'il ya
des collections de la statuaire s'il y a
du patrimoine environnemental également
de naturel
c'est un point majeur qui a été mis en
valeur au sein des dossiers et qui a
beaucoup plu également au groupe de
travail qui a labellisé le site le
challenge est important puisque en fait
j'ai une double vocation ici non
seulement la conservation d'un site et
d'un patrimoine culturel avec ce jardin
historique mais aussi c'est de
réinventer forme de jardins forme elle
est régulière et de le réinventer dans
un usage moderne et de mettre en valeur
la naturalité du site en fait
avec ses 53 hectares classé monument
historique et ses 44 hectares gérés par
l'office national des forêts le domaine
de marly le roi rassemble les amoureux
de la nature il ya une étude de faune
flore qu'il vient d'être
déjanté par le pv sur l'humanité entière
et donc on a des résultats qui nous
prouve qu'on est sur un site tout à fait
exceptionnelle l'argent parisienne n'a
pas tant que ça et les amoureux
d'histoire c'est un domaine de
villégiature qui a été créée par louis
xiv de manière quasiment contemporaine à
celui de versailles il faut savoir que
le domaine de marly a été construit en
une vingtaine d'années petite vingtaine
d'années ce qui est exceptionnel quand
on connaît le faste qu'il a connu
donc c'était vraiment une demeure
secondaire voire tertiaire 2014 ouvert à
l'année le domaine de marly le roi est
aujourd'hui un lieu de fête de visites
et de promenade où les touristes les
sportifs et les familles cohabitent dans
le calme
pour refermer ce journal un rendez vous
culturel qui revient à montigny le
bretonneux la 14e édition du salon elle
lisait locale se tient ce samedi à la
librairie et du pavé du canal c'est à
partir de 15h l'occasion de rencontrer
neuf auteurs du territoire et pour en
parler avec moi alors en garde un bon
soir ancien gérant de la librairie du
pavé du canal oui c'est un retour
finalement pour cet événement si une
formule qui a déjà été proposé souvent
par la librairie ni tout à fait sauf
qu'on a renouvelé la un peu le modèle
parce qu'on réunit finalement neuf
auteurs sur un même instant d'habitude
on nous avait quatre auteurs puis quatre
auteurs à cette fois ci on veut vraiment
avoir tout le monde en même temps
surtout qu'on a un espace qui est dédié
pour ça en fait avec la bulle et
animalsace on a réussi à mettre ce
plateau un peu culturel où il ya un peu
de d'animation culturelle de
d'expositions de rencontres un peu de
théâtre et donc des hauteurs où on peut
recevoir paisiblement également tous ces
auteurs les j'aime bien jean que c'est
une joie de les recevoir il ya eu des
années compliquées on le sait avec la
crise sanitaire de leur proposer des
animations des événements autour de la
littérature oui tout à fait surtout les
auteurs locaux parce qu'on a quand même
une forte demande de la part de nos amis
qui sont sur le territoire donc voilà il
fallait qu'on les reçoive de nouveau et
vraiment ça nous fait plaisir de
remettre sur pied alors il ya des
auteurs de renom qui viennent à la
librairie du pavé du canal pourquoi
mettre cette fois ci en avant les
auteurs locaux parce que le tissu du
territoire est quand même bien important
est que en tant que libraire nous
implanter sur le territoire c'est normal
qu'on reçoive aussi tous les acteurs
locaux et culturelle de du territoire
donc voilà donc c'est important qu'il
faut enfin il faut qu'ils aient des
grands noms il faut également ouvrir les
librairies indépendantes aux auteurs qui
ont un peu moins de 2 de communication
tout autour d'eux mais pour le coup
c'est important de le rouvrir
paisiblement et calmement le lieu alors
je reprends votre site internet vous
partagez cette statistique 8 français
sur 10 m écrire et plus de la moitié ont
déjà eu envie d'écrire ou honte écrit un
livre est ce que l'objectif de ce salon
c'est pas aussi de dire aux personnes
présentes qui vont venir rencontrer ces
auteurs vous pouvez aussi franchir le
pas et écrire tout à fait c'est
également ça c'est que pour franchir ce
pas et franchir le rubicon finalement
c'est pas si compliqué que ça parce que
l'auto édition existe mais même si
l'addition est importante et il faut de
la re lecture mais pour le coup voilà on
rend plus on peut rencontrer son public
donc ce moment là est aussi très
important parce que ça va être le moment
de partage et donc ce travail qui
souvent personnelles et de le partager
avec les autres qui sont les auteurs
présents et ce qu'ils sont tous
yvelinois tous franciliens du coup alors
ils sont pratiquement tous yvelinois
pour le coup on a une professeur de
français dans un collège de montigny on
a des marques asia on a des vies sinois
voilà on n'a vraiment pas mal de monde
du coin et c'est déjà en fête qui
viennent à la libre et qui son client a
livré et qui viennent me proposer leurs
ouvrages qu'on a lu nous et qu'on dit ok
venez avec venez avec nous dans l'
aventure de ce mini salon local et on
peut découvrir quelques-unes des
couvertures des ouvrages de ces auteurs
qui seront présents d'ailleurs si on
regarde dans le détail ces couvertures
nada pour tous les goûts il ya du roman
des récits plus personnel de la
littérature adulte jeunesse il également
la littérature jeune adulte il ya la
bande dessinée enfin voilà les
pratiquement tous les pans de l'édition
sont représentés la wii tout à fait ça
demain samedi à 15 heures quel est le
programme comment ça va se passer
concrètement concrètement on va les
accueillir sur ce lieu qu'elle abîme et
voilà on va faire une petite
présentation de chacun je pense chacun
aura sa place comme un vrai beau salon
de bonnes en bonne et due forme et puis
on va les accueillir donc on va faire
une présentation un peu biographique de
chacun et on va attendre que le public
arrive et ça c'est voilà ça tient aussi
à cette réussite tient au fait des
auteurs qu'ils aient communiqué au tout
autour d'eux parce que voilà c'est ça
reste un événement lequel a besoin
d'inscription peut venir directement sur
place samedi oui tout à fait
vous venez à laitages à sur le plateau
de la bulle est justement vous parlez de
cet espace maintenant dédié pour
accueillir ces rencontres avec les
auteurs ça veut dire qu'il ya d'autres
événements ça va se multiplier dans les
prochains moins et vous prévoyez est-ce
que d'autres gros événement alors on
travaille sur la rentrée donc voilà on
est en plein cela va arriver c'est la
rentrée ça va arriver pardon est donc
voilà laurent gaudé qui sort un ouvrage
chez actes sud on aimerait bien l'invité
donc voilà enfin oui forcément on
travaille sur ça mais pratiquement
toutes les semaines on a une animation
dans la durée et donc ça va pour le coup
là on a dû de forcément de la
littérature on fait aussi un peu de
travaux manuels ont fait un peu de
mosaïques ont fait des des cours de
youku des défunts voilà on en étant un
peu la palette de la culture et donc ce
14e salon lisait local c'est ce samedi à
la librairie du pavé du canal à
montigny-le-bretonneux message pas été
spectateurs pour les inciter à venir
peut-être battre continue à dire est
qu'il ya des auteurs locaux qui font des
très bonnes choses il faut venir les
découvrir et toutes les informations
bien sûr sur le site internet du pavé du
canal à on y retrouve bien sûr si toutes
les références présentes en librairie
merci beaucoup laurent guérin d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau et je le
rappelle vous êtes le gérant de cette
librairie le pavé du canal qui est
installé à montigny le bretonneux voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité en juin à l'information
locale continue sur tv soixante dix huit
avec reportages et émissions spéciales à
suivre sur un 30 est notre site internet
également nos réseaux sociaux belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]